hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy
thank you for joining us today i'm
kristen decervo the chief learning
officer at khan academy and i'm excited
today to talk with nick ferroni who's
going to talk about what would it look
like if we really appreciated teachers
i'm excited to get on with that before
we get started a couple reminders first
at khan academy we are a non-profit and
we rely on donations from folks like you
to keep doing the work we are if you go
to khan academy.org donate you will find
a place where you can easily contribute
and help us continue to work towards our
mission
second we want to thank some of the
supporters who have helped us address
the coven 19 crisis including a t
general motors and fastly
and finally if you are interested in
listening to this discussion or any
other discussions that i've had or sal
has had with some of our uh homeroom and
egg talking guests you can go to home
with sal at wherever you get your
podcasts and hear audio versions of
these chats
so with that let me welcome
mr nick ferroni nick thanks for joining
us today
thank you so much for having me chris
i'm just finishing my school day
currently
yes so let me tell folks a little bit
about you you are a
high school teacher who teaches math and
cultural studies and
mentor a diverse group of students
including founding your school's gsa gay
straight alliance and feminist club and
i'll brag on you a little bit uh nick
was named one of 100 making a difference
for his commitment to education reform
and has also recently um
been uh been named as oh i lost my place
there um as well as recently named the
upstander of the year by the human
rights campaign i like that title of
standard of the year for your advocacy
and support of lgbtq youth so welcome
and it is a pleasure to talk to you
today well thank you so much and history
and culture studies are definitely my
expertise
but thank you thank you so much for
having me it's so great to be here i've
been looking forward to so much
great so i like to start by asking
people about their career path did you
always want to be a teacher did you
how did you how did you come to be where
you are today wow that is that is such
an interesting question i always i
always joke around and say as a kid i
wanted to be a superhero a philosopher
philanthropist a comedian an actor
and an adventurer so i became a teacher
you know it's just there you go
we're all encompassing one
i i had amazing educators growing up
teaching was not my major focus i always
kind of thought i wanted to be a mentor
a coach
in that field
i went to rutgers
to play football and i majored in
history at that point that's kind of why
i started to realize maybe education and
history was kind of
what i would want to pursue
indiana jones was probably one of my
biggest influences i'm like if i can do
that if i could go on adventures um in
the weekend and be a professor
but
it's
after college ironically enough i ended
up acting uh i was actually waiting for
a teaching job to open up my old high
school which i've been teaching at
my alma mater now for 19 years which is
such an interesting experience in itself
but i was waiting for a teaching job my
cousin's a big agent so she was like let
me send you on some castings and make
you some money while you're waiting to
to teach
i ended up booking a few jobs i ended up
on a soap opera
and i started to do that while i was
subbing in my school so i ended up to to
work more and more i mean i wasn't a big
time player i was a 10 and under which
meant i had a few lines every every so
often and eventually they had me on more
and more and i was getting more
opportunities and then a teaching job
opened up my old high school
so i had to pick between pursuing
something that i wasn't really
passionate about and i wasn't trained in
i didn't think i would ever be good at i
definitely had imposter syndrome or
become a high school teacher
the irony being i went from putting on
one show a day to six shows a day to an
audience that does not want to be there
i will say this with absolute certainty
every great teacher could be a great
actor not all great actors could be
great teachers because our job is so
performative and it's so about
engagement
but i'm now finding myself in my 19th
year teaching my alma mater uh it's the
greatest job in the world if teaching
was my only job it would be the easiest
job in the world but there's so many
other facets
and so that's how i'm back here now at
union high school
i love that acting is the thing you do
until a teaching job opens up that's
a great way to uh to think about the the
potential hierarchy of careers that we
think about so you said you had some
great teachers and it's teacher
appreciation week which we'll talk some
more about but given that what do you
have a teacher or two that you'd like to
specifically point to is influential for
you
god i i luckily i was very fortunate to
have so many i mean my history teachers
growing up just made me passionate about
history you know passionate people make
you passionate
but i would say whenever i talk about
anything uh i always talk about mrs
martino my kindergarten teacher
and she to me was the epitome of
educators
i came from a very
catholic upbringing so being left-handed
my italian grandmother was not very
happy about that she would constantly
try to force me to be right-handed and
obviously as a kid that's kind of
traumatic because you feel like
something's wrong with you and then mrs
martino was the one who got me to
embrace being left-handed she would read
me books about left-handed people and
the irony being i always tell these
stories whenever i do any press i do a
lot of press for obviously in reference
to being an educator and to advocate for
teachers i always tell the stories about
how mrs martino i would have the
toughest days of my life as a student
coming in and she would always nurture
me and read to me and then one day in
particular i always say how
i was having such a rough day because my
grandmother again was forcing this kind
of on me uh to be right-handed because
left hand was sinister in her mindset
she brought me over to the toy box and
she said you know i want you to pick
your favorite toy and of course being a
kindergarten student i
reach in grab the he-man action figure
she let me keep it it was the greatest
moment of my life so i always tell the
story on how teachers are so good at
knowing
what their students need emotionally
the irony being mrs martino and i have
kept in touch
on social media on facebook so whenever
i do a story kristin i'll always send
her a link to it i didn't see her since
i was her student so always send her the
links and i always get the same response
you know i'm so proud of you i love you
so much say hi to your mom
and finally i did the today show and i
told the story about how my kindergarten
teacher mrs martino let me keep this
human action figure it was such a simple
act but it meant so much to me
and she replied back to me i love you so
much i'm so proud of you it means so
much that you think so much of me but i
have to be honest with you
so
you'll know where this story is going
because in the history of histories
i don't think a woman has ever told a
man in any situation that she has to be
honest with them and something good has
come out of it
i don't think you've ever sat down your
husband or spouse or partner said we
needed to talk and it'd be something
positive so i i messaged her back and i
was like is everything okay of course i
made about her and she's like why i need
to be honest with you i just i want to
clear something up
and i am who i am because of the
confidence that this woman built when i
was a young child my mom's amazing but
mrs martino just added that confidence
and that empowerment
my thought was is she going to tell me
that i wasn't a talented kid and i i was
annoying and i
shocked her
oh my like nick i have to be honest like
you really blew me away i thought you
turned out to be enough you know i was
waiting for that response and so she's
typing my heart's beating 100 miles an
hour because the woman who i am who i am
because of is going to crush me at any
moment
so she's typing and again i'm in my 30s
when this is happening so my
kindergarten teacher is going to destroy
a 30 year old man's ego and a heartbeat
and finally her comment comes up and
she's like you know nicholas i love you
so much i'm so proud of you but
you keep telling people i was your
kindergarten teacher i was your
preschool teacher and you keep saying it
was the he-man action figure and it was
a fonzie doll
and of course
i go back and i text my mom like mom do
you remember the toy that miss martino
let me keep and she's like what that
weird little fonzie action figure i was
like it was onesie doll
so
to me 30 years later
this woman remembered the moment the day
even the toy
i felt the only only logical response
was to surprise her and go see her
so that is a picture of me surprising
mrs martino 30 years later she opened
the door she started crying i started
crying it was pretty intense
the other thing i want to point out to
elementary school teachers you are the
most patient people on the planet
because you have to wait 30 years to
find out if you did a good job
you know
i get immediate gratification being a
high school teacher but yes please don't
wait 30 years to thank your elementary
school teachers on how amazing they were
but it's like that's one of the moments
and it was just such an amazing moment
for me because you know it's teacher
appreciation week it's it's never too
early to thank a teacher who impacted
your life but it can be too late
so i always encourage people to not wait
for that moment to to take advantage of
it but yeah mrs martino to me is who i
who i try to be as an educator every
student walked in the classroom feeling
loved and she would always tell me
you know and she'd always say
they will forget what you teach them but
they will never forget how you made them
feel when they were in your classroom in
your presence and that's something as a
teacher has become my mantra
that was my takeaway part of my one of
my takeaways from that too was you
didn't remember the detail you actually
didn't even remember which grade she
taught but you remembered the way she
made you feel and i also might have said
example
i might have also suppressed the fact it
was a fonzie doll he man's a lot cooler
like even that fact that detail the fact
that she remembered
but yeah it's like she remembered those
moments and it's and i didn't but it's
like i just remembered how loved and how
much i felt
yeah yeah and the confidence that it
gave you that she gave me to yeah
absolutely that's it i love it love the
fantastic story i'm going to have key in
on one other piece you mentioned was
reading books that made you feel like
you were seeing yourself in the book too
which
is another thing that i feel so
important for for folks to be able to
see themselves and
get that from books i feel like is such
a gift
well children's books i mean i don't
think people realize the impact they
have not only on the not only for
children to see themselves but for other
children to see other children and to
see different groups and see diversity
and it's like i mean it's and she was so
incredible way before our time like way
before the inclusive nature we live in
she read books on every group
everything's children with disabilities
different races and it was such a
powerful lesson it's like an i mean i i
i am the person i am because of the
empathy and compassion and understanding
that was instilled on me at that time
and i think that's why it's so important
that educators are supporting that of
providing inclusive
inclusive books and there are so many
amazing children's books out there
which everyone has seen
and the sad reality is i can imagine
that there may be some classrooms where
there are students who don't feel seen
because they don't have access to those
short books or hear those stories
yeah yeah
so that was a great tribute to your
teacher let's get into this idea of
teacher appreciation week you've been
very vocal that there shouldn't even be
a teacher appreciation week tell us why
you feel that way and and what you what
your stance is
i mean i i think
everyone should be appreciated i mean we
shouldn't have mother's day you know you
shouldn't eat a day to appreciate
mothers but we do we need that reminder
and then i go back to annoying my mom
the 364 days of the year
teacher when it comes to professions and
people have said it for a long time if
you have an appreciation week you're
probably not being appreciated
and it's kind of that that that
celebration or it's everyone likes to be
appreciated on a larger scale when it
comes to teacher appreciation week
i'll be honest i used to be
uh part of my language but i used to be
that toxic positive person where
you always have to be positive
regardless you can't address any
negatives you can't
show any vulnerability it always has to
be a positive positive focus about
definitely as an educator at same times
i'm you can still be positive and be
understanding and empathetic and also
try to push for change
and when it comes to teacher
appreciation week it is it's such an
interesting thing because it made me
re-evaluate my whole profession it also
made me re-evaluate on if teachers are
really appreciated which kind of i'll be
honest when i was thinking of ways to
amplify teacher stories and teacher
concerns this year
one of my thoughts was maybe we should
do an anti-teacher appreciation week
campaign where it's get rid of teacher
appreciation week for other things
and obviously i kind of drift away from
that because it's still it's still a
nice gesture and it's still nice to be
recognized
then i kind of came up with the thought
of maybe we should just allow an
open-ended question of teacher
appreciation week is great but what if
we really appreciate teachers if we
appreciated teachers what do we need to
change
and not that we're not appreciated but
at the same time what we want to change
within the system within our professions
so that kind of led me to push a little
campaign where i wanted people to share
not only teachers but anybody who's
supportive of public schools and
education and education in general to
just share what they feel needs to
change for teachers to truly be
appreciated
so tell us about that this hashtag if we
appreciated teachers what is that what
does it become
it's to me it's awareness uh obviously
tweets and posts and has hashtags don't
change society don't change culture
but i always feel like as a history
teacher i've always found that
change doesn't happen without awareness
until you bring awareness to things it's
even as a person like when i realized
became aware of certain things it made
me more active uh to help change the
things that i can change
and something as simple as if we hashtag
if we appreciated teachers was just an
opportunity to give educators and
everyone a point to share what they feel
needs to be changed not only so that
teachers feel appreciated so that we we
could be better teachers for our
students we could be better partners for
our spouses we could we could have
certain resources and certain needs met
so we don't continue down this
i hate to say it but this possible
struggle of of
a teacher attrition that will leave
schools without enough educators to make
sure that every student has a teacher in
front of them
so i i got i reached out to as many
people as i could as many educators and
there was great feedback and great
responses and just great thoughts and
some of them i never thought about
because again
you know being a man i did not think
about i i'm aware of paid maternity but
i never thought about how much it
affects the teacher profession because
we are a profession predominantly of
women so it was great to see everyone's
responses it was hopefully useful and in
the way of making people more aware of
what we're concerned about that when we
go on social media we're not complaining
you know me
confiding about the stresses of my job
is not complaining about my job it's
wanting to
be a better person so i could be better
resourced and a better teacher for my
students
uh teachers when you help teachers you
help students
it is not either or you don't support
students and then for not supporting
teachers or if you support teachers you
don't support students we are
intertwined
so i just wanted to do something like
this to help bring more awareness to
the concerns not only
not only in america but just nation
globally and and internationally because
there's a lot of common concerns that
teachers are struggling with and i just
want to fix it before we lose so many
amazing educators which i i'm afraid
might happen
so we saw on the screen there some the
responses that teachers and
all sorts of folks were posting
do you have your own list what would
your list be if we really appreciated
teachers
i mean my list is always probably the
most simplistic list uh it's always
called the the core needs
that
i've i'm in my 19th year as a teacher
there's not a single year i haven't
worked an extra job there was years i
was working three jobs on top of
teaching on top of of doing my main job
i as i always say teaching's one of the
most important careers that you have to
work other careers in order to still do
your first career if you were about to
get heart surgery and you found out your
doctor was driving uber for 12 hours
before the heart surgery you'd be a
little suspicious or cautious or
concerned if you found out your airline
pilot was again working in a in a target
or working in a factory right before
they were about to fly to plane you'd be
concerned i mean i feel the same way
about teachers like we expect so much
and we give them with so little so
obviously the fact that we don't want to
be millionaires uh it'd be nice if we
were
but just a livable wage where we can
not only not only live but support a
family if needed that's why we feel like
most men go into administration because
it pays better as a man i cannot support
a wife and a child on my teaching salary
which is also another problem which
exposes education the
the fact there's it's predominantly a
female profession that we don't value
the work of women as much as we do men
and so the idea of paying teachers a
livable wage you shouldn't be working an
extra job if you're an educator unless
it was by choice if you want to that is
fine it shouldn't be a necessity uh the
fact that we we buy our own supplies and
we beg for supplies online to me is
still one of the most insane things i
love
i love resources and sites that allow
teachers to crowdfund but at the same
time we shouldn't have to
if every teacher who was crowdfunding
online was standing on a street begging
for supplies that would be national news
every single day
so
educators shouldn't be expected to to
to
buy the resources that they're not
provided with
and we shouldn't be expected to to at
least if we do spend our money we should
be fully
fully protected i'm sorry uh the sensor
light went out which happens in a school
so i'm gonna move real quick
sitting in one position for too long i
understand i know i know
i'm pretty animated i'm italian my hand
should be enough for the sensors to keep
going
i'm married in italian and inherited
some of the african women so i get it
these lights need to be a little more
more obvious on the censorship side but
when when it comes to the resources the
fact that it's expected of educators and
the fact we do it and people are like we
should stop doing it but we could
continue to do it but fight for the need
so we don't have to do it
so and even just something simple
i think
the pandemic we
we went from being celebrated to being
heroes then to being accused of just go
back to work we need people to babysit
you know we weren't valued we aren't
invested in
and it's i've never seen a profession
so celebrated but so demonized or so
undervalued at the same time
and i feel like with educators we just
want society to invest in us
the same way we invest in our students
and that's not asking for more that's
just asking for enough so i feel like
those three things from a public opinion
the investment
from from the resources every classroom
should be fully resourced every teacher
should never have to come out of pocket
and every student should have
teachers who have all the resources that
they need
and then just for the fact that if i
only had to work one job i would be a
better teacher than i am and i give my
all to teaching already
so
i shouldn't have i again it just it
breaks my heart to show shows but my
grub hub driver of weeks ago he's
wearing an njea shirt which is our union
in new jersey and i hesitate i'm like
are you a teacher and he said yeah you
know and he looked down he's and we
started talking and i was like do you
want to do this he said no i come right
from school i teach till 4 and then i
come right here and do this for six and
he's a new father he has to do it
that should people should be as angry
about that as they should anything else
so just more support you don't have to
have a child to support schools and
education i think education is the only
investment that really benefits
everybody outside of universal
healthcare education is the next best
investment that benefits everybody
i'm sorry for that kind of emotional
rollercoaster ride but
it's just
yeah it's like my uber driver and like
talking to him and just seeing that it's
like it's heartbreaking and it's and
he's not the only one majority of a lot
of teachers a lot of teachers tend to
work extra jobs just a supplement
yeah
the other thing that i know from
teachers that um are in my family and
that i know is that if they're not
working another job they're working
their teaching job
weekends and evenings and
doing all that work is there a
how do you feel like we should address
that piece where there's so much on the
teacher's plates
well anybody who says teachers only work
days and have evenings and weekends and
summers off doesn't know any teachers
and the running jokes
somebody tweeted this they're like
saying teachers only teach during school
days or work during school days is like
saying tom brady only works 15 sundays a
year because that's that's when he
actually works as if he's not working
every other day preparing everything
else
uh if if we were paid by the hour going
back to being a millionaire we would be
millionaires if we were paid by the
actual hour of work we do because
there's so much
and the irony being
if
i would never encourage a national
strike at the same time part of me feels
like if educators
only did their contractual job the
education system would fall apart if we
didn't do the beyond the extra hour work
the working on the weekends we wouldn't
be able to do our job but i feel like
the education system would absolutely
crumble it is almost impossible to
fulfill our duties as educators within
our contractual hours we're expected to
work outside of that and if we don't
nothing will get done so we almost feel
obligated to do it because again we
don't want to punish our students
because
we're not allotted enough time to get
papers lesson planning
professional development done within the
school day
so what is the solution for that is it
that we need
more teachers so that any individual
teacher has less of a workload or what
is the how do we
help fix this
well i mean it's
no teacher should have a class
especially elementary school of over 15
or 20 students i mean the factors
kindergarten teachers with 30 or 40
absolutely blows my mind i have high
school students classes of 30 as well
to me it's impossible to develop
relationships with students when you
have class sizes
i'm sorry
i'm recording yes it's all right thank
you all the interruptions
this is the perfect i just need one
announcement and one student to walk in
with the late pass even though there's
no students just to show you what
happens on a regular school day
is great
this is not planned this is all life of
a teacher this is all life of a teacher
totally understand um i you you
mentioned you know you should we showed
some of the things that other teachers
have said and also you shared your
thoughts can people still participate in
the campaign and share their thoughts
about
this
absolutely i i we have a template a
blank template hashtag if we appreciated
teachers
and if you are a parent if you're an
advocate if you you just if everybody
has a teacher in their family
just share fill in the blank it's an
open-ended question share what you feel
needs to happen to truly let teachers
know we appreciate that
and the templates it's very simple it's
on my socials i believe we'll be sharing
it on here as well
so
if you're watching this yeah yes it'll
be in the chat uh
for obviously this video and all you
gotta do is just make a copy very simply
insert what you think needs to happen
for teachers to be appreciated truly uh
to be appreciated and then share it and
use that hashtag and let's just keep
awareness uh this conversation can't end
after teacher appreciation week because
obviously
we're still in the school year we'll be
back to school next year we can't come
out of these past two years without
making some change for the better in
education and for educators
so all i ask is take three minutes uh to
think of what you need think needs to
happen and share it and just kind of
join this little movement and help bring
awareness to people who may not
understand education or have connections
to teachers
great
we have a number of parents who often
engage with us
what what kinds of things can parents do
uh to both support classroom teaching
practices or in the ways they talk to
their students
well i would say i mean parents my heart
goes out to you as well because we are
in this together
it is not parents versus teachers we
want to see your child succeed so much
we want to work with you which i hate
when parents and teachers tend to get
politicized and put against each other
but as parents
reach out to your child's teachers and
as teachers reach out to your students
parents and just find out what we can do
to work with you and
as far as supporting your classroom as a
parent find out how many students are in
your child's classes find out if the
classes are fully resourced if they're
not show up to those board meetings run
for school boards speak out in defense
of of the staff
put pressure on school boards i'd say
but
if you put pressure on a school board
they will be more inclined because then
they feel like the community is behind
this message
so
be very involved and understanding
what's going on in the classroom as far
as if your child's in classroom of 35
students i'd be concerned with that as a
parent i would think my child's not
getting the best education i would then
support hiring more teachers to make
sure those class sizes can go down so
just work with teachers reach out to
teachers we are here for you
we want to do whatever we can from our
end to not only support your mission but
to help what you're doing but just also
to set your child up to succeed
fantastic so we've talked a lot about
how
difficult and challenging the job of
teaching it is what keeps you inspired
what keeps you doing this
i mean outside of all the interruptions
and chaos and dysfunction
it's
i had
we had miss usa come by school on monday
to surprise our students and staff and i
always use my platform to in to get
opportunities for my students
uh the photographer they hired to shoot
me miss usa's visit and videotape it was
my former student who i had a sop as a
sophomore in class
my greatest moment as a teacher was
helping him get his first published
photo in a national magazine which was
of me
and as educators
it's
teaching is it's we enjoy nothing more
than seeing our students go on to be
successful and pursue what they love and
to be
you know to be happy successful
uh empowered human beings i would say a
teacher someone who dedicated their life
to the success and happiness of other
people's children
but seeing my students thrive
interacting with them uh even days when
there's battles we every day is not rosy
with students they they they're
emotional beings i'm an emotional being
there are days i don't have my coffee
i'm a little more irritable than i would
be on a normal day you know so it's just
those interactions and i will say this
with absolute certainty i know 99.9 of
teachers would agree with me
if a teacher ever leaves teaching and a
lot of them are it is not because of the
students that is the only reason
teachers will endure what we're enduring
and what we've been bearing for so long
is because we do it for our students we
have not become teachers for the salary
the fame or the summers off
but the fact that that it's interesting
enough where
for some of us it's our dream job the
fact that we have people leaving their
dream job should tell a lot of people
how unbearable
some situations have become
but it's it's my students it's that
interaction they keep me inspired i'm a
better person i would not be half the
person i am today if not for having new
groups of students every year who hold
me to a higher standard who better me
you know it's like that makes me a
better person
fantastic it has been a pleasure to talk
to you today
if folks want to hear more from you or
or find out what else what else are you
up to coming up with what do you have
coming up
you could follow me on my socials uh
instagram and twitter is at nicholas
ferroni
i'm also collaborating with kahoot i'm
hosting a little live game show for them
every two weeks
our first kahoot game show is tomorrow
and it's not only for teachers it's for
teachers students games enthusia gaming
game show enthusiasts our first ones
tomorrow 3 p.m eastern time at cahoots
instagram so join us it'll be a lot of
fun
but just feel free to message me dm me
or reach out if there's any way i could
help
especially as educators i love sharing
the stories of amazing teachers and i
feel like not enough people hear those
stories
fantastic thanks so much for your time
today thanks everyone who joined us and
we will see you next time
thank you so much
you